And with that I'd like to turn to our subject for the morning,
which is about the third.
It's the third in our series of lectures on bubonic plague and I'd like to talk
about the effects or some of the effects of Boob onic plague on European
culture.
We've been trying to suggest that plague had a major impact on European society
and I want to be arguing that that impact was felt not only on political events
but also on culture and intellectual life.
And I'd like to look at that this morning,
but I wanted to remember that when we're talking about those effects,
I'll be trying to say it was the effects not only of play gets self as a
disease,
but also the impact of the organized reaction to plague of the anti plague
measures and the sense that for the first time society had means that were
effective and could protect itself against this dreadful outside visitor.
Well,
let's start again at the beginning and as you know,
there is a biblical interpretation for the themes of this course and this is the
one that you're now well familiar with.
This is the fall.
This is Adam and Eve,
uh,
as painted by the greatest of all,
perhaps the greatest of all,
plagued painters.
Jacobo Tintoretto who was a painter in Venice and lived from 15,
18 to 1594.
Well,
you know,
this is the story of genesis that Adam and eve tasted of the fruit,
that they were forbidden and as a result,
they were expelled from the garden and for the first time became subject to
death and also to disease and illness.
And if we move forward,
uh,
this is the next step.
You saw the original sin.
This is massage shows,
uh,
one of the great painters of the Italian renaissance.
This is his painting and the Brancaccio chapel in Florence of the expulsion from
the garden.
And you know,
they're looking extremely miserable.
Not only are they going to die and become ill and experienced pain in
childbirth,
but they're also,
and I'm sorry about this,
they're going to have to work.
So,
uh,
this is a tremendously painful experience and you can see the pain written and
their faces,
uh,
of Adam and eve.
So that in a way is a story of our course.
And I'd like to talk now about some attitudes towards what followed that his
illness and death.
Just before the arrival of the block,
and I'd like to refer to the work of a French historian who died fairly recently
and was one of the great,
perhaps historian of death.
His name is Felipe Audios.
And he had an idea that before the black death,
he talked a bit as death tamed.
That is,
there were ways that people had beliefs,
practices,
and rituals that help them to face the issue of our mortality,
to cope with loss,
to heal the tear that was caused in a family or community,
the loss of a member of a family,
and also to express grief and Depay ones,
last respects.
And there were two great aids in doing that.
One we might say was the RS Modi MD,
which was the art of dying.
There were certain rules that you should be aware of that would prepare you for
the final moment and the passage from this life to the next.
And then there were what were called a Momento Morty,
which is a reminder of death.
That is a reminder.
You should surround yourself with reminders that it's time to get ready because
any day could be the last and death could come very soon.
We'll see the art of dying portrayed and instructions sometimes in paintings or
engravings also in books.
Uh,
how did I properly according to Christian doctrine,
who should be there?
What are the last rites?
That is extreme unction,
the final confession of sins,
the last communion and [inaudible],
the funeral rites,
the laying out of the body,
the wake,
the procession with perhaps a town crier announcing the event,
the funeral service and a burial ceremony with the blessing and internment and
consecrated ground.
And finally a funeral meal for surviving friends and relatives.
Leading themes in this are,
um,
themes of solidarity,
dignity and community.
And in this slide if the artist more and we see a dying person and habiting two
worlds,
the natural world,
he's about to leave with possessions,
friends,
family and home and a supernatural world he's about to enter and that only he
can see,
but as represented by angels and devils vying for his soul.
We can also see in another example by Nicola Prusa,
also seventh great 17th century French painter who this is a painting of extreme
unction.
It's an illustration of the good death to which everyone should aspire.
Now the 17th century,
the time of Defoe's great work also witnessed in Britain the publication of the
work of one of the most famous of all riders on the theme of ours,
Morty and the art of dying.
That was the extraordinary Anglican preacher and Bishop Jeremy Taylor,
who lived from 1613 to 1667 and wrote two major works,
both of which have gone through edition after edition.
They were so popular and so influential.
The first was called the rule and exercises of holy living of 1650 and the other
was the rule,
an exercise of holy dying of 1651 Taylor argued that this life is short and
unimportant and so we should use our time primarily to prepare for the eternal
world,
making certain that we die with our worldly affairs in good order and with our
souls in a state of grace prepared to meet our maker on Judgment Day,
his books.
Then we're instruction instructional manuals on how to do that and he reminds us
that there really isn't a moment to waste,
especially with the threat of plague ever present with sudden death.
That could happen at any moment now.
So Felipe rds thinks then the opposite of the good death is death by bubonic
plague.
That is something we might call death unleashed a sudden mass death for which
society had no defenses and to no prep,
no one was prepared.
This was the sudden death is more as the day pen Tina sudden death,
which was always feared because sudden death catches a victim unprepared with
his will,
unwritten in this world and his soul in a state of sin that could lead to
eternal damnation and the next and death from plague was not only sudden,
but as we know now agonizing and dehumanizing,
it often meant that the software was alone and abandoned and it was death
without the attentions of the clergy without funeral rites and proper burial
where your body was hurled unceremoniously into a mass plague pit burned perhaps
thrown into the sea,
picked over by vultures and crows nor remember.
Don't think that this fear of Moore's rape and Tina was something medieval and
very distant from us or simply early modern.
The historian drew Faust and her extraordinary recent book on the American Civil
War.
This republic of suffering places the fear precisely of Moore's today,
Penn,
Tina,
at the center of her account of the civil war,
it was a widespread anxiety pervasive among the soldiers on both sides of the
conflict and it recurred again,
again in the letters they wrote home.
Total war like boob.
Onic plague provides unlimited opportunity for an unprepared in sudden death
that could set us all on the wrong path for eternal life.
Well,
literature also gives expression to this new and horrifying reality.
You've seen Boccaccio and his introduction to the Decameron.
You're reading defoe and the Journal of the plague year.
You could read about it again.
Income moves the plague or Edgar Allen Poe's short story masque of the red
death.
Remember too that another aspect of Moore's rape and Tina the sudden unprepared
death was the fear of premature burial.
The certification of death in the early modern world,
say at the time defoe was writing was extremely imprecise.
The only really certain indication was putrefaction and so those religious
rights of laying out the wake or the funeral procession and so forth were
practical that they allow time and they insured.
Observation to be certain that the dead person really was dead before being
interred.
But plague.
On the other hand,
we've seen the plague regulations.
They mentioned stead or rapid,
hasty burial with no attention and no observation.
An isolation raised a real danger of being buried alive and in time of epidemic
diseases that swept populations,
this fear of death,
which was very pervasive and we'll come back to it when we talk about cholera in
the 19th century when funeral,
the Sarah Cemeteries had all sorts of experiments with providing caskets with
little bells above and a rope underground so that someone could raise the alarm
if they woke up unexpectedly.
So the plague then really led to death unleashed.
So let's look at some of the portrayals of it and painting and sculpture from
the plague.
Centuries of this second pound Denman,
remember from 1347 to 1743 here's a bas relief of PR PJ.
This was the plague in Marsay.
Um,
and uh,
I think one can see the extraordinary portrayal.
I wanted to move on them to this particular painting.
One of the most important of the plague years.
And this again is Pusan whom you saw earlier telling you how to die properly,
what the good death should look like,
who should be there and all the rest.
This is his famous painting of 1631 now in the Louvre in Paris called the plague
of Ashdod.
Let remont me remind you,
it's again a biblically inspired painting.
Let remind you of what osh dog was.
The story is from the first book of Samuel in the Old Testament.
Asha Dodd was a city in the holy land near Gaza,
occupied in biblical times by the Philistines who worshiped the idol Dagon the
Philistines,
defied the Israel lights in battle and confiscated the Ark of the Covenant as
war booty and set it up in the temple of Dagon in our stock.
And so the book of Samuel tells us,
and so it was the hand of the Lord was against the city with a very great
destruction and the Lord smote the men of the city,
both small and great,
and they had Mrr odds in their secret parts.
A special reward to any of you who can tell me what an Mri rod actually is.
But anyway,
this slide is about the destruction of the Great Temple of Dagon.
You can see that here.
This may be,
uh,
the Ark of the covenant.
It is,
then again,
we can see it's a representation and painting of plague as being a punishment
for divine anger and for sin.
The,
some of the things we can note our,
the gruesome and particular particular details,
we can see that there are rats scurrying.
Um,
you know,
the role that routes played in play.
Let's look here.
We can see our friend Rob Roth tourists,
uh,
playing a starring role,
or let's notice again in the foreground,
um,
the attempt,
the terrifying haunting attempt of a baby,
uh,
to suckle.
It's mother who's dying.
I'm sorry,
that was in the preceding.
Uh,
and that's here in the foreground a,
and we'll look at this
person here,
uh,
and we can see the pastor by holding his nose because of the stench of the
victims and the fear of Miasma.
Or let's look at another portrayal.
And this is Pedro Gaetano.
Uh,
the plague of the late 17th century,
or quite a terrifying picture of by [inaudible] Datta the plague of Naples in
1656.
And while we look at this,
let's think of the reference that it's making.
You can see that things are happening in the heavens and this is Naples being
devastated by the plague,
their plague pits and all the rest of it.
And this picture,
I think we should remember how people thought of this.
It seemed to be an acting out of the book of revelations,
the day of the apocalypse,
the dacs that I,
the day of Wrath and the Lord's judgment.
When the lamb opened the SA great book closed with seven seals.
And that's the reference in Bergman's film to the seventh seal.
And in the book of revelations,
let me remind you of what people were thinking at times like this.
In chapter six,
it says,
and I saw when the lamb opened one of the seals and I saw and behold there was a
white horse and he that sat on him how to bow and he went forth,
conquering and to conquer.
And we need open.
The second seal there went out another horse that was red and power was given to
him that sat there on to take peace from the earth that they should kill one
another.
And when he had opened the third seal,
I beheld a black horse and he that sat on him at a pair of balances in his hand
and he opened the fourth seal.
I looked and beheld a pale horse and he that sat on him was death and hell
followed with him.
At last,
the lamb opened the seventh seal and seven angels appeared bringing the wrath of
God.
There was thunder lightening and earthquake.
The sea turned to blood.
The grasses were burned up,
the water's turned to warm wood.
The Sun and moon were smitten on a bottomless pit open.
And I saw another sign in the heavens,
great and marvelous,
seven angels bringing the seven last plagues for in them.
It's filled up the wrath of God.
And I heard a great voice out of the temple saying to the seven angels,
go your ways and pour out the vials of the wrath of God upon the earth.
And the seventh angel poured out his file into the air and then came a great
voice saying it has done.
I think that's what's happening in the heavens here.
We'll other examples of death unleashed are portrayed in the theme that was
common in European painting in uh,
the time of bubonic plague during the plague centuries.
And that's the theme of the triumph of death,
which is often complete with the horsemen of the apocalypse.
That I just read you about.
Under usual scene is a great cart pulled by oxen,
driven by the figure of death wielding a great side.
Well before him there goes the angel of death blowing the trumpet and all around
you may see dead people and graves that are opening and skeletons.
Let me give you
one of the scariest paintings.
I know.
This is Peter Broil goal,
the elder who lived in the 16th century and this is the triumph of death now
hanging in the pronto in were in Madrid.
And if you look at the details,
I think it becomes all the more disturbing.
The closer you look at it,
you see death coming with his side and mowing down the population in their
mouses,
which is what bubonic plague,
uh,
does in particular.
Or we can look at another artist,
and this is under on Montana who died in 1506,
his painting the triumph of death.
There were other new themes in European art that emerge during the plague
centuries.
And one of these that are showing a minute,
which is not this,
uh,
but we'll be the theme of Vonda toss a new theme in European art during the
plague.
Centuries when death was unleashed in Europe repeatedly Vonda toss as a theme
flowered in the 16th and 17th centuries.
Now what did it mean?
Well,
Vanitas toss paintings were meant to display the temp rolled goods of this
world.
Flowers,
perhaps fruits,
symbols of learning and culture,
such as musical instruments or books or signs of earthly achievement in wealth
like gold and jewels.
But they're juxtapose to striking and more shocking symbols of what's meant to
be the deeper reality of this transitory fragile life that we live and the
imminence of death.
And so alongside these earthly things,
you'll see a skull,
a candle who's flame is just going out an hour glass marking the passage of
time,
the crossbones.
And the message is not also is a biblical one vanity from Ecclesiastes.
He's,
let me just read you a sentence.
What profit?
Half the men of his Labor under the sun,
one generation passeth away,
and another generation come
in an age of sudden mass death.
Human achievement was few tile and in permanent.
And you should instead be preparing yourselves for the true reality of death and
the everlasting life.
Now this we can see directly linked to what you're reading about Jen to fall
here we have the bill London bills of mortality and 1664 to five years that you
know,
and they're coming to love.
And this is the illustration that introduced the bills and it helps us to make
the direct connection between Plagge and the iconography I've just been talking
about.
You'll notice that the symbols are the classic Vonda toss symbols of the 17th
century.
You see the skeleton,
the crossbones,
the shovel,
um,
and all the rest of it.
All around the edges,
the skull,
the hour glass here,
the time is running out.
And indeed you'll see right here that this is the inscription is Memento Mori.
This is to remind you that death is coming and could strike at any moment and
you had best prepare.
Or let's look at another painting of this century.
He's these centuries.
This is Lucas Fortune Nagel.
Well,
this actually isn't,
I'm sorry,
this is a different one,
but let me move.
You can see in this painting again,
the candle going out.
You can see the skull and human achievements,
all our vanity,
um,
as the,
the lesson or this rather,
this is the one I was mentioning Luteus Fortunate Eagle in the 16th century in
Germany.
This is Hans Bork Meyer and his wife,
uh,
painting a 15,
27.
And the point is that they're looking in the mirror,
they shade the true reality of themselves,
which is their skulls after death.
And so this is reminding us that this is the true reality that lies beneath all
of us.
Or let's look at another painting.
This is Herman stain.
Vike a painting called Vanitas of 1640.
I'm trying to show you paintings from different countries from England,
France,
the low countries,
Germany and so on.
Uh,
this is the low countries and this painting hells in Leiden and uh,
is quite clearly about exactly what we've been talking about.
The candle,
the skull or the books that are evanescent or more subtly,
but quite famously,
this is Hans Holbein,
the youngers painting,
um,
called the ambassadors,
which now hangs in London and the National Gallery.
It's an icon,
ironic commentary on the Court of Henry the eighth,
all about the painting.
You see the display of symbols of wealth,
power and learning,
elegant costumes,
the globe,
the book,
musical instruments,
but in some bird juxtaposition to the mall is an apparent smudge in the
foreground of the painting.
But if you look at it closely,
what it actually is,
is a large and perfectly constructed skull seen from a different perspective.
A technique known as an hour,
an a morphosis or let's look at one more Vonda toss.
This is Renard descent on today.
17th century painting called appropriately Ivana Toss.
I think you've got the picture.
Another theme of the centuries Ah,
of death unleashed is the theme called the dense dos macabre the dance of death.
Now let me stress that once again,
this is not a school of painting.
This is part of the AIGA and iconography.
It's the theme in the painting.
It appears as a common motif in European art from the mid 14th century to the
16th and paintings and prints and very importantly on tombstones.
It began with the black death and with the 18th century and the vanishing of the
plague.
It becomes rarer and rarer.
It more or less fades out.
The dos macabre portrays death as a skeleton,
inviting people of all ages,
ranks and sexes to join in the merry dance of death and death is usually armed
with a sigh or an outro or dark and often plays a musical instrument.
In the words of the Catholic encyclopedia,
the Bach death brought before popular imagination,
the subject of death,
and it's universal sway as never before.
At this time,
death appeared as the Messenger of God,
some mending,
mend the world beyond the grave.
During those years,
many churches lit and knock,
did literal dances of death or transformed it into a play conveying the idea of
the fragility of life and the near notice of death and the need for repentance.
There are other examples and I'd like to show you five slides from Saint Mary's
Church of Lubeck in Germany,
a glorious mural from 1463 one of the glories of the renaissance in Germany,
but unfortunately it was destroyed by allied bombing in the war and so there's
only a black and white reproduction that I can show you,
but the theme comes across quite clearly and is a good example of the dance
macabre.
What it is is a portrayal and separate paintings of a whole society suddenly
summoned by the angel of death,
the bubonic plague.
The first one is the pope and the emperor being summoned by death.
It doesn't matter who you are,
everyone falls victim and time of plague.
We're here.
We see another level of society that cannon and a nobleman being called again by
death or the third is the parish priests and the artists and who are also being
asked to take part in the dance and then the priest and peasant,
the whole of society in other words,
is being stricken by mass death.
And here we have youth,
a maiden and a baby,
so we have a portrayal in a sense of universal death.
This was important in the time of bubonic plague.
There was another major development of the plague centuries and this was the
emergence of cults of famous plague saints,
Saint Sebastian,
Sun Rocco and St George.
And let's look then at four pictures of Saint Sebastian from four of the great
artists of the plague era.
You remember why Saint Sebastian was so important because the hours were symbols
of the plague and Saint Sebastian is offering his body to defend humanity
against the wrath of the Lord.
And Saint Sebastian is a theme who becomes very important in these centuries.
For the first time in European painting.
This is Sandro Botticelli,
Lee's painting of Saint Sebastian of 1484.
Or let me show you another major painter.
Raw feels Saint Sebastian,
or let me show you.
We will.
Nice picture of him or finally from the low countries,
Hendrick tear,
Brogan's early 17th century painting,
1635 Saint Sebastian.
It was also,
as I said,
a time of cult,
the cult of another saint.
And this is sound,
or we can call him son at all call.
You know,
his life already.
He was from Montpellier in France and devoted himself during his travels to
tending the plague stricken,
uh,
in Italy and protecting the faithful.
He was after his death.
Then his intercession was invoked across Europe and it's called spread from
country to country.
Often we see Sebastian and Rocco painted together.
This is Andrea dominant on know Christ,
embracing the saints.
Sebastian here to his right and son Rocco to his left.
And you can almost always tell that son that Oracle has,
uh,
the blue bowl on his thigh.
Uh,
it's clearly the bubonic plague that's being referred to,
um,
here or Francesco Vicenza Leo,
this is the Madonna,
uh,
between Sebastian,
um,
here and sanded Alcor.
Um,
there in addition,
that was larger scale than just paintings.
It also,
uh,
affected architecture across Europe and churches were built to sun all go across
Europe,
in France,
in Austria,
in Vienna and Rome.
But I think if we're going to talk about plague and its impact on the built
environment and architecture as well as painting,
I think the best place we could go is Venice.
Venice,
as you know,
because of its site in the Mediterranean,
at the center of the trade routes was scourged again and again by bubonic plague
and was the place that first devise the anti plague measures.
So Venice has a deep association with bluebonnet plague and it's left its
imprint in stone and on canvas.
So I'd like to look at some of,
if you were to visit the Venetian Venice,
you would see that it's whole urban landscape is deeply affected by Buena phonic
Plagge.
Also,
even the gondolas are in fact our reference.
That's why their block two,
bubonic plague from conveying the bodies the time.
This is the church in the of Saint Mary of health of the fifth can built in the
1530s.
And what it's doing is it after the plague had passed.
This is a church that's built to commemorate the passage of plague and to thank
God for allowing his wrath to be assuage and for health to be returned.
And so that's why we have one of the most important churches in Venice is Saint
Mary of health.
And these are a couple of closer pictures of it.
And that's moving into the interior.
Let me also show you another church.
This is the Church of the redeemer and it's a church also built a at time of
plague to thank God for the assuaging of his wrath and the survival of the city.
A closer picture and the uh,
we'll move on.
This is the,
uh,
again,
one of the glories of the nation art.
It's called the,
uh,
squallor going on the sun that all call,
which is the great school of song and Alcor.
Let's remember what the school meant.
There were so 300 or so called schools at Venice in the 16th and 17th centuries.
What they were is confraternities associations of laymen,
including the leading trades of the city.
Some of them had large and wealthy memberships and played a major role in the
government of the city and amassed enormous wealth.
The functions of the confraternities were originally devotional and given the
exposure of Venice to the plague,
it's not surprising that the very largest and most powerful of the schools chose
sons and Oco as its patron saint.
And this is,
it bears the name.
It constructed a magnificent building and commission,
the greatest Venetian artist of the century,
jock protein Torah to decorate it in veneration of Sangudo call and indirect
rivalry to the Sistine Chapel in Rome.
So let's move inside.
MMM,
yeah,
we are.
Um,
and we'll see that we're looking at when these plagues scenes,
we'll be seeing that.
We're going to look at the,
uh,
at the magnificence of the art.
And this is the interior of it.
And I just wanted to show you that at the height of the painting is Jane told
Astros Painting of the triumph of sunblock code son Rocco,
the great plagues sat achieving his reward in heaven and going up to God plague
also affected across Europe.
Let me also say another theme in the urban landscape,
uh,
involved plague columns and you can see these particularly in central and
eastern Europe,
a great plague column in the center of Vienna or also in Pilsen and the Czech
Republic or in here's yet another in Hungary.
Now in these plagues scenes of course,
remember that by definition we're looking at works by survivors who sense of
horror was tempered perhaps by a bit of relief.
If it were possible to have works by the victims,
perhaps the scenes would be even more wrenching.
There were also aspects that aren't mentioned in the literature under
unknowable,
but perhaps probable what happened to those who suffered from the plague and
then were recovered was their first Tila t affected whether a longterm sub
quilly a neurological deficits where their psychological effects that we would
now term post traumatic speced stress syndrome.
But in our discussion of flag,
I also want to say that there were some,
a couple of speculative large scale conclusions that I want to Hinton.
The presence of [inaudible] over four centuries as we've just seen had a major
impact on religion,
on culture,
on societal attitudes toward life and death and left a major imprint on
architecture,
on painting and sculpture.
And in addition,
I want to speculate for a moment and say that we might also think that perhaps
the plague and especially not the plague itself,
but it,
the triumph over it by the means we described last time may have been a factor
that helped to transform European intellectual history.
Now it's a great,
one of the great cliches that the 18th century,
the age of enlightenment was a great age of optimism and belief in progress.
But I'd argue that perhaps the belief in progress required some tangible
material foundation and the,
this was grounded and a new sense that life in fact was becoming more secure and
that perhaps mankind couldn't master.
It's an environment and its destiny.
And so I would argue that it's very significant that the first great medical
conquest of at least public health conquest resulted from the application of the
power of the state of administrative measures in the plague regulations.
And it's no coincidence then that the 18th century and during this time the
state came to be seen as a source of redeeming power that could transform human
life in society.
Here was an impetus towards reform and to rethinking intellectually medical
history.
In a sense,
one could argue was one factor that helped to sound the death knell of the old
regime dramatically in successfully demonstrating human's capacity.
That is men's capacity to make his or her own history here was the basis for a
new faith in reason and the creative potential of political power,
perhaps it's suggestive to remember the Jones Jacques Rousseau,
the founder of modern,
uh,
revolutionary political thought began his,
and one of the heroes of the enlightenment began his career in Venice,
which for a time he regarded as a model regime.
And that his time there included a mentor of month of reflection as the
underwent a term of quarantine.
And the Great Venetian.
Lots of rough tone.
But again,
I want to avoid giving any suggestion that I want to propound a germ theory of
history as a historian,
I'm opposed by training to Monaco causal explanations of major events.
And so what I'm not saying is that the conquest of the plague caused the
enlightenment on not saying that,
I nearly want to note that the conquest over the plug first and we'll be talking
next week about smallpox second,
were extraordinary influences,
triumphs over the two most feared diseases of the 17th and 18th centuries,
the first conquest over infectious disease.
And I would say that that wasn't a million miles away from being a background
influence on the coming of the age of the enlightenment.
I would also speculate that the triumph over plague first and then small pumps
also played a role in the coming of the industrial revolution.
Dot.
The plague and small pox had been enormous breaks on demographic growth and the
growth of the economy and the conquest of the plague by the 18th century
followed by a victory over smallpox,
had a major impact on launching a great age of European population growth and
population growth and turn was a precondition for the coming of the industrial
revolution again,
that I'm not saying that the conquest of plague was a mono causal explanation
for the coming of the industrial revolution.
I'm saying simply that it was one of many preconditions that it was a growing
population that provided that endless supply of free laborers for factories,
mines and sweat shops.
And it also provided a growing market for industrial products.
Demographic change then supplied a large home market for industry.
And having made that argument with regard to plug next week,
what I'd like to do is to turn to the second major epidemic disease.
If plague was the greatest feared disease of the 17th century and from the 14th
through the 17th in the 18th century,
the most feared disease was smallpox.
And I'd like to look next at smallpox.
It's impact.
And on the second great development of a public health measure,
a very different one,
which was the public health measure of vaccination.
So that's where we're going next.